hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wird heute gibt es kein rezept
von mir sondern ein kleines dankeschön
ich habe heute meine 25.000
abonnentenzahl erreicht und hab mir
überlegt wie ich euch glücklich machen
kann und einfach meinen dank mal
zurückgeben kann
ich habe gesehen dass ihr meine zwei
letzten videos mit bildern ceylan oder
harald oder manfred so toll geteilt habt
und wir haben uns jetzt ein kleines
gewinnspiel ausgedacht und zwar verlosen
wir zehn mal zwei karten
zwei eintrittskarten für die über den
ceylan show am kommenden freitag also
diese woche bereits am 13 12 in der sap
arena in mannheim
das heißt für euch das ist das heimspiel
für den brand und die show wirklich
krank und richtig toll
ich war davon zwei jahren das erste mal
und mein herz hat die ganze zeit nur
geklopft weil es so toll ist dort in
dieser atmosphäre und ich wünsche euch
und ich wünsche mir dass jetzt
zahlreiche leute mitmachen bei diesem
gewinnspiel
ihr könnt mit machen indem er mein
letztes video ich werde es gleich
nochmal als facebook post auf meiner
facebook pinnwand posten doch heiße ich
übrigens auch selbst orten welt und da
werde ich dieses letzte video vom
zweiten advent als von gestern posten
diesen post müsst ihr dann teilen
und da müsste bitte aufpassen dass ihr
dabei der privatsphäre einstellung der
post auf öffentlich macht damit ich auch
sehen kann wer ihn geteilt hat ansonsten
sehe ich nur 200 mal geteilt aber keine
namen
und das ist ganz wichtig das gewinnspiel
läuft dann bis mittwoch mittwochabend um
20 uhr werde ich das ganze dann aus
losen und am donnerstag brauche ich bis
15 uhr eure namen damit ich euch eben
mit aufnehmen kann und am freitagabend
wird es dann so seien bei der
veranstaltung dass ich euch dort quasi
empfangen
wir machen einen gemeinsamen treffpunkt
aus ich gebe euch die karten und dann
dürft ihr euch in der sap-arena
aussuchen weil es da nämlich eine freie
sitzplatzwahl gibt wo ihr euch einfach
zwei plätzen suchen könnt von denen aus
ihr dies das event eben sehen wollt also
dann genommen auf west island bis
kommentieren und bewerten
das hat mich nämlich jetzt zu meinen
25.000 aarhus gebracht ich freue mich
auf viele weitere auch auf viele weitere
videos und wie gesagt teilt das video
das ich jetzt gleich im anschluss an
dieses video posten
und dann freue ich mich schon auf die
gewinner verkündung bis bald